Heidi Klum and Tim Gunn say cookie dozen
to Project Runway after 16 seasons one
day you're in and the next day you're
out et has learned the longtime host and
mentor are exiting the show to bring a
new fashion reality series to Amazon I
don't think I should answer any
questions on that just because it's
still all a little bit all over the
place which explains why Heidi was super
tight-lipped about the new season of
Project Runway back in July and again
when we asked her about it just two
weeks ago we are so excited for the next
season of Project Runway I know you're
busy with AGT do you have any updates
for us like when do you guys start and
when can we expect the next you have a
dream list of guest judges one show at a
time right but Project Runway will go on
Bravo issued a statement saying the
network will move forward with a
rebooted version of the series and
they'll announce their new host and
mentor very soon well working with Heidi
is know an incredible joy while we're
thrilled Heidi and Tim will continue
their 14-year professional partnership
here's hoping they won't have to ditch
those infamous catchphrases oh he
doesn't make it work Go Go there was no
summer for them they got work
actually people don't ask me to say it
they shouted at me oh really
Jim make it work you don't have to do it
like on people's answers how I do and
I'm happy too I mean we're so lucky as I
have I have to do a few dozen to so many
people can you please record this I can
in addition to Heidi and Tim designer
and judge Zac Posen announced he would
also be exiting Project Runway releasing
a statement that read in part runway has
led to incredible opportunities and I am
currently at work on some new projects
that I am very excited to share with you
soon stay tuned
I wish the show and everyone much
success always
[Music]
[Applause]